what's going on people today I'll be
breaking down part three of Attack on
Titans final season in around 10 minutes
or less in case you're new to the
channel you should know that I've
already made videos explaining Parts one
and two of the final season which you
can find in the description below and I
also made a much longer video breaking
down the Easter eggs in part 3 however
like I said the video you're currently
watching is a 10-minute overview for
anyone who wants a speedy explanation so
without further Ado let's just get into
it okay so part three of Attack on Titan
kicks off with Harley getting flattened
by the rumbling as entire generations of
refugees get wiped out what was
especially tragic about this is that one
of those refugees Was A Boy Called
Ramsey who was someone that Aaron had
gotten friendly with the year before
back then Aaron happened to be walking
by as Ramsey was getting beaten up by
some Marans and although he initially
hesitated he did step in to save his
life the problem here though is that
Aaron felt like he had no right saving
someone who he knew he was eventually
going to kill and so at the time he
broke down crying as a confused Ramsay
just listen to him ramble about his
reasons for destroying the world in the
present day the W Titans then Crush
Ramsey and his whole family while in a
separate area of Marley Aaron's own
grandparents also get squashed in case
you may have forgotten this is gish's
Mom and Dad and from the looks of it
they were locked up by the marlean
police and then just abandoned in this
cell as the Titans began approaching
having seen his dad's memories though
Aaron didn't really have any love for
his grandparents and personally I doubt
he even gave them a second thought after
he left Liberia as the rumbling
continues to March the steam coming off
of the Titans gets so intense that it
sets people on fire While others wisely
decide to end their own lives before it
can happen to them simultaneously Aaron
watches the chaos from inside of his
founding Titan and in his head he was
celebrating the fact that he finally
achieved the freedom he wanted ever
since he was a child trapped Behind the
Walls during his childhood the wall in
shanto always felt like a cage to him
and he believed that if he could reach
the other side he'd see all the amazing
things that he read about in arman's
book however the reality was that the
outside world is a super disappointing
Place filled with humans who want them
to die hence why he's now just wiping it
all away using his founding Titan Aaron
then summons alen into the PA Dimension
but as you can see when Alman returns to
the real world he immediately forgets
about the interaction from this it's
heavily implied that Aaron wiped his
memory of their conversation because
otherwise it Nob brainer that if Armen
had remembered he would have told the
rest of the alliance about what just
happened anyhow on the ship he and Annie
have a slightly Awkward Moment where
it's obvious they both like each other
but sadly this is no time for romance as
the world around them is literally
getting Torn to Pieces later that same
night the alliance then finally arrives
in the marlean city of Oda and as a
reminder the reason they came to this
place was so that the engineers would
have a place to get the flying boat
ready in peace one important detail is
that wrapped around this flying boat was
Dynamite that was put there by the agas
but rather than throwing it away Armen
suggests that they take it with them to
potentially use against the founding
Titan the alliance then goes to question
Yelena about where Aaron might be
heading and she reveals that the most
likely location is a base called Fort
salta the reason this is the most likely
location is because fort salta is where
Marley stores a lot of their airships
and explosives and Yelena had previously
warned Aaron that it might be a threat
as a result he's heading over there to
destroy Marley's final defense and once
that's done they won't have anything
that could possibly stop him throughout
the night onyankopon and the engineers
then work on preparing their flying boat
and they do get it fully ready around
Sunrise following this the alliance
splits into two groups with one half of
them planning to confront Aaron while
Annie and the rest of them plan to just
stay behind on the ship that they
arrived on unlike the rest of the
Warriors the female Titan had lost the
will to keep on fighting given that in
her mind her only motivation was to see
her dad again but now that Liberia's
been trampled it was reasonable for her
to assume that he had to be dead unknown
to her though in part two of The Final
Season Mr lart began a small Uprising
and along with rina's mother peak's dad
Gabby's parents and a bunch of other
eldians they were all making their way
to Fort salta the plan here was that if
they could reach the fort quickly enough
then they can avoid the rumbling by
flying over it with an Airship before we
get to that though back in Oda the
alliance had their plans disrupted when
flock randomly shows up out of nowhere
the last time we saw him he was shot
down into the ocean by Gabby and it
pretty much looked like that was the end
but no he did survive and he was dragged
through the water all the way from Elia
to Oda as if that wasn't enough don't
forget that flock was also the only
Survivor of Zeke's Rampage in season 3
so his plot armor was genuinely getting
somewhere close to rhina levels in any
case now that he was in Oda fl's main
aim was to protect Aaron from from the
alliance and so he indiscriminately
shoots the place up and in the process
makes a few holes in the flying boat
although Mikasa kills him immediately
afterwards the damage had already been
done as the engineer said it would take
an hour to repair the fuel tank that was
especially bad news since the rumbling
was on their doorstep by this point and
until the fuel tank is fixed it would be
impossible for them to take off in this
moment what the alliance needed was for
someone to help slow down the rumbling
and initially Armen offers to be that
person his Colossal Titan form would
have the best chance of stopping the
other Titans but the rest of the group
wanted to save his powers in case they
needed it against the founding Titan for
that reason Hani steps up to be the
sacrifice but not before they appoint
Armen as the new commander of the scouts
admittedly that title doesn't have the
same ring to it anymore given that the
scouts are now just five people who were
considered to be traitors back home but
still it was at least a nice gesture
poni then tears down a huge section of
wall Titans to the point where the
Titans are tripping over each other and
struggling to move forward gradually
though they do make it to the hanger in
the end but by the time it happens the
holes in the flying boat was sealed and
the tank was at least partially refueled
therefore thanks to hanji becoming a
martyr everyone else was able to get
away with Annie kiomi and the warrior
candidates escaping by ship while
onyankopon flies the alliance towards
fort salta on the journey there the gang
discussed exactly how they plan to deal
with Aaron and Peak suggests that they
simply use the Colossal Titan to blow up
the founder the reason for this idea is
that right now they have no clue where
Erin's real body is located and so
destroying the whole thing would be a
guaranteed way to stop him that being
said peak obviously has no loyalty to
Aaron whatsoever so she's totally fine
with killing him whereas from armen's
point of view his preference is to just
talk to his friend and convince him to
end the massacre without the need for
any fighting Levi then suggests an
alternative solution which is that
instead of targeting Aaron they try and
find the Beast Titan who was last seen
when he got absorbed by the source of
all living matter if the alliance could
somehow locate Zeke inside this pile of
bones and kill him once in for all then
Aaron would no longer have a Titan of
Royal Blood and without that the
rumbling should come to a standstill as
the group then theorizes about aon's
motivations and mindset the man himself
abruptly summons all of them to the P
Dimension where he makes his position
incredibly clear in short he tells them
that nothing they say will ever change
his mind about doing this Mass Slaughter
and the only way they can stop him is if
they endend his life meanwhile on the
other ship the rest of the alliance head
in the direction of hisu which is of
course ki's home country and on the way
there Falco comes to a huge realization
usually when someone inherits one of the
nine Titans it's normal for them to see
memories from the previous user but in
this case things were slightly different
although Falco did inherit the draw
Titan it was Zeke's spinal fluid that
titanized him in the first place that's
why his shifter is essentially a hybrid
between the draw and Beast meaning he
can see memories from previous Beast
Titans as well one of those memories was
of someone flying way high above the
clouds and Falon reveals to everyone
that it feels like he can do that too
now switching over to the eldians who
Escape Liberia when they eventually made
it to Fort Sala there wasn't a single
Airship available that they could use
ordinarily this would mean that they're
all going to die but in a surprising
turn of events the airships that had
left the base were all heading towards
the founding Titan the idea was that
each of the ships would fly as close as
they could to the founder and then
accurately drop thousands of explosives
on top of Aaron and some of the Titans
around him as well if this plan had been
done correctly then it might have had a
chance of working if they targeted his
head and you know evaporated his real
body but to be fair Aaron never really
gave them the opportunity to do that as
the airships were approaching he used
his powers to manifest a replica of the
Beast Titan that was made purely out of
Titan hardening it's crucial to note
that this this replica is not actually
Zeke but rather it's a copy of Zeke that
is directly connected to the founding
Titan due to this connection we can
assume that either Aaron or yamir is in
full control of its actions and the
appearance of this Titan caused all of
the airships to panic instead of getting
close like they initially planned to do
they were all told to just release the
explosives they had leading to most of
the bombs being inacurate seconds later
the fake Beast Titan then destroyed
every last Airship with a pitching
assault and ending any faint hope Marley
had of stopping the rumbling themselves
thankfully for them on yankon showed up
just in time with the rest of the
alliance then skydiving out of the
flying boat the seven of them then land
on top of Aaron with Rina in particular
transforming into the armor Titan and
tackling the fake Beast Titan to the
ground at the same time over and for
Sala his mother and all of the other
Warrior parents they couldn't believe it
cuz by this point they just assumed that
their kids were either dead or at best
alive somewhere on the island to see rer
and Peak here was something no one was
anticipating and in part four we'll see
how the rest of it plays out with that
said that was my Speedy recap of part
three of Attack on Titan the final
season and be sure to subscribe to the
channel if you want to see my thoughts
on the final ever episode that's coming
out very soon thanks for watching as
always and until the next one peace out